hey guys my name is Jeff today is the
fifteenth of April and you're tuned in
to guess what news hair plugs new war
zone firefight mode is in beta testing
and you can play it right now just like
the firefight mode we've come to expect
in halo teams and players will take on
waves of tougher and tougher enemies and
also complete objectives across five
rounds only in war zone firefight these
matches will play out on war zone maps
and will apparently feature the most
on-screen enemies in Halo history the
beta is set to run from today up until
the 18th of April and if you already own
the game no further download is required
this is an in development version of war
zone firefight so some technical issues
are to be expected 343 industries are
hoping to gather feedback from the beta
to make the final version better when it
officially arrives sometime this summer
235 developer Capcom is hopefully
getting serious about dealing with rage
quitters in the games I post on the
official Street Fighter Twitter accounts
explains that Capcom plan to roll out a
system to deal with rage quitters in it
April update and more details are on
their way soon the current issue is that
there is no penalty system in place to
punish players who quit out of games
early Capcom have tried to monitor
players abusing the system and encourage
player reporting but the long-term plan
is to find a permanent solution Capcom
have said moving forward we will be
making a sweep each week based on
accounts in our system that have
abnormally high disconnect rates
particularly at the end of the match and
will reset their league point a box art
for The Witcher threes next expansion
blood and wine has been revealed Kuralt
is looking dashing as always with the
sword and wine goblet in hand while a
harpy looms over him a similar image
posted on NeoGAF which is reportedly
from a retailer in Jakarta suggests the
content will be sold in stores as a
download code which will give you access
to the DLC and to gwen's decks no
official release date has been announced
for blood wine but a jun 7 release date
was previously reported before being
distant
just by developers that are correct read
the dlc will take place in a new region
called Tucson where inevitably shift is
probably about to go down and said a
proactive previously said that the size
of blood and wine when added to the
hearts of stone DLC will make a game
that's as big as the witcher 2 let me
know down in that comment section if
you'll be playing blood and wine and
head to gamespot we've got stories on
Deadpool to and more avatar sequels that
is everything I have you today but do
let me know what mattered to you and
join me again tomorrow for the five
biggest stories of the entire week I'll
feel it